foreign
sociologist Emile durkheim said that one
of the functions of punishment is it
firms up our sense of group solidarity
so when our group's under threat for
some reason when our values are under
threat if we can create an outgroup that
it's legitimate to punish
we can reaffirm our sense of solidarity
I think I think we saw this a bit in the
pandemic our sense of social solidity
was really in Jeopardy but sort of by
definition just social distancing
um it's not a surprise that Boris
Johnson in the summer of 2020 in his
speech about how we're going to recover
from the pandemic said he's building 10
000 new prison spaces
um because it creates this Us and Them
it's a slightly different experience for
me because uh for me this is kind of
where the X was on that map of
concentric circles when I was growing up
my brother was in prison and so it was
my dad and my uncle
my dad's from Liverpool which I think at
the time was quite a sort of a lot of
poverty quite a sort of chromogenic area
my mum's side of the family from the
East End which has a huge kind of uh
historic adversarial relationship with
the police where you could be sort of
excommunicated for talking to a copper
and so for me I've kind of I have a
different relationship to this sort of
out group it's a complex one it's not
one necessarily of unconditional warmth
and regard
um I think I I Googled ambivalence and I
found this wonderful image
um by ambivalence I don't mean the way
it's sometimes misused to say sort of
detached or I don't care or you know a
kind of shrug but this sense of um just
having this kind of cacophonous
uh attitude in your head these multiple
viewpoints
um
you know I was I was greatly pained by
seeing my brother go to prison it seemed
totally unnecessary the War on Drugs
wasn't going to get him to give up his
heroin addiction
um they couldn't possibly punish him
more than he was punishing himself at
the same time when my dad went away I
did feel the kind of relief I felt like
well actually maybe I'd become the
person I am today because I had that bit
of space and uh I sort of lost this kind
of overbearing violent figure in the
house yet within all of that was this
sense of
it could have been me or it will be me
one day a feeling of inherited guilt
that I'm going to be visited by the same
fate and so I couldn't consider my dad's
punishment without thinking well would I
like to be punished that way what would
it do to me how is it going to
how would it deform me further how's it
going to deform him further
um so it's a it was a really sort of
messy uh State
um what I want to do today is say how
what what sort of vantage point that uh
that experience has given me on a more
like social political level when it
comes to uh prisoners and just just what
I've experienced at work and in my
family what happens when we Exile people
so I told you about my family coming
from the East End uh my Uncle Frank uh
when he was 14 uh we did three months in
a bore stall on remand uh if anyone
doesn't know about borstools they're
these kind of short sharp shock regimes
that they used to have where teenagers
would basically have to do hard labor of
a very futile hard labor such as digging
holes that were eight feet deep and then
filling them back in at the end of the
day
um that was a very brutalizing
experience for him shortly after he got
out he was in trouble with the police
again one night when he was 15 he broke
into a corner shop to steal a crate of
Coca-Cola cans he's not really into
Coca-Cola but he's into the buzz of
stealing from shops at that point the
police show up uh they catch him he's
not a very good thief at this stage and
they they think well Coca-Cola is not
really much of a charge but if we can
say that he stole the cash box or was
trying to steal the cash box didn't get
a good charge here so they sat him in
the back of the police car
two police officers either side of him
and they needed to get his fingerprints
on the cash box so they grabbed his
wrists and tried to prize open his hands
uh he just clenched them as tightly as
he could in defiance and they tried to
peel them open and incriminate him
now I I know lots of stories from the
East end that are a bit like that
um the police and ordinary people who
just uh it's a game and they hate each
other the response for someone like my
uncle coming from a working class family
no opportunities to kind of uh very few
opportunities to kind of escape this
confrontation with the police uh was he
thought well if you want to see a
criminal
I'll show you a criminal
uh and it's something that is so echoed
uh uh in in the likes of Pentonville or
Brixton or belmarsh for me I I hear
people just sort of say this all the
time that uh when the states are telling
you that you're awful that you're
criminal when they're stigmatizing you
like that
your way of taking charge of that
situation sometimes is to try and be the
worst possible thing you can be worse
than what even they think you are
um obviously this has really negative
effects for people's behavior and for
Society on the whole uh if that's one of
the only places they have to go uh
there's a man uh in the book
um uh called DK and he talks about how
when he's in prison when he comes back
to prison he's been in and out for much
of his life he feels this kind of sense
that he can relax
and it's not necessarily that he's
talking about being overly
institutionalized although there may be
some of that what he's saying is
in prison when I interact with people
when I I don't know lend someone a tea
bag or a cigarette or when I just chat
to people on the landing uh I'm just
seen to be doing a nice thing to help
someone out outside
it's like I'm stuck behind a
two-dimensional existence
where um
I can't break free people are always
interpreting me according to my
criminality that that's fundamental and
he's sort of he's flattened much more in
the outside world whereas in prison uh
you know
let hearers without sin cast the first
stone people tend to see beyond your
crime and see sort of who you are a bit
more so obviously the the effects of
exiling people is that they will make
another community
but they will make a community amongst
those who will accept them which is all
sometimes a kind of criminal subculture
so I think the way we do things uh our
lack of uh Affinity familiarization or
casting out of the circle of prisoners
is really harmful
uh it leads to more crime pretty much
uh that then brings us to the question
of well what would it mean to feel some
kind of affinity or connection or human
regard for someone in prison that sounds
a bit weird I don't necessarily want to
hold hands and sing Kumbaya with a
murderer you know it's uh we can't be
naive about this we can't be naive about
the fact that people uh can be very
dangerous in prison and they they may be
sort of quarantined from us for a good
reason
I'm going to say that I think there's
two things
that need to change in order for us to I
think have a bit more space and human
regard for people in prison one is to do
with social and material change which is
really really important and the other is
to do with a change of our attitudes how
we think about stuff which you know
talking to people at a philosophy
Festival I'd be really interested to see
what you say about that in the Q and A's
so on the social and material Level
uh this is a more familiar site in
modern Britain
um when I was growing up I kept hearing
this phrase from the kind of working
class Community I lived in which is
um bed and breakfast bed and breakfast
prisons like bed and breakfast I heard
this deep resentment
for the fact that prisoners were getting
three meals a day
and at the moment we are living in a
country where people can go to work they
can work very long hours they can work
every day of the week and they are
skipping meals
um so it's it's one of the sort of
tragic ironies that the the working
classes are not always but uh very often
kind of punitive
they want tougher sentences they want
prison to be harsher
um
I don't take that face value there may
be some people who do I think that
arises from
the feeling of deprivation that people
have in their own life
we talk about Norway and Scandinavia and
these countries that seem to have really
forward-thinking prisons with kind of
the therapeutic interventions and
reintegration programs
the reason they can flourish
is because people's quality of life in
those countries it is generally good
there are very few people in Norway who
are jealous of someone in prison
and I think if we want to change our
prisons we you know I think this is the
general sort of abolitionist sentiment
that we have to uh improve just social
material conditions across the board uh
the second thing that needs to change is
a little bit more esoteric uh it's to do
I think with our kind of attitudes
um uh in the book there's a chapter
called luck and it's about moral luck uh
and I'll explain what that is now but
um I describe being in a classroom
and uh I tell my students about these
two worlds that exist these two
imaginary worlds one is a just world
where good things happen to good people
and bad things happen to bad people and
everything is as it should be it's
perfectly meritocratic
and the other is a luck world
where everything is random whether you
are the judge or the prisoner whether
you're the king or the peasant
uh it's completely random uh I think the
national sport in the luck world would
be Snakes and Ladders if you win at
snakes and ladders it doesn't really
mean anything if you lose it snakes and
that is it doesn't really mean anything
uh in the just world I think uh
chess would probably be their national
sport I don't know a lot about Chess I'm
going on a limb here but as I understand
it it's a game with no random factors
except for who goes first
so uh it's it's it's it's its design is
much more meritocratic I think what's
interesting and difficult about our
world is it's at the murky Borderlands
of these two worlds
is that Justice plays A Part effort
Merit whether you did something good or
bad or not it it's significant but so is
luck right
so is
your where you're born in terms of the
social economic hierarchy
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas